Nos dicen: "Jack necesita 22 piratas para cada
dos barcos piratas que gestiona. Completa la
tabla con razones equivalentes", y aquí tenemos
una columna para el número de piratas y otra para
el número de barcos. Bien, queremos encontrar una
razón equivalente a la razón 22 a 2, es decir,
22 piratas por cada 2 barcos, eso se ve reflejado
en la primera fila de nuestra tabla. Observa,
nos dicen que 22 piratas navegan en 2 barcos.
Una forma de resolver esto es pensar en cuántos
piratas hay en cada barco, si queremos mantener
la misma razón podemos darnos cuenta que,
si dividimos 2 barcos entre 2 para
mantener el número de piratas por barco,
tendremos que dividir también 22 entre la misma
cantidad: 2 /2 es 1 y 22 también entre 2 es 11,
es decir, acabamos de encontrar que por cada barco
se necesitan 1 piratas, esto nos ayudará a llenar
la tabla. Si tenemos 5 barcos y en cada barco se
necesitan 11 piratas, entonces ¿cuántos piratas
necesitamos en total? Bueno, necesitaremos 5 veces
11 piratas, es decir 55 piratas, eso quiere decir
que la razón de 22 piratas a 2 barcos es la
misma razón que 55 piratas a 5 barcos, que es
la misma razón de 11 piratas por barco. Bien, en
la siguiente fila nos preguntan ¿cuántos piratas
necesitaremos para 11 barcos? Bueno, si sabemos
que por cada barco se necesitan 11 piratas,
entonces para 11 barcos necesitaremos 11 veces 11
piratas, y 11 x 11 es 121; entonces se necesitarán
121 piratas para tripular 11 barcos, eso quiere
decir que la razón de 22 piratas a 2 barcos es la
misma razón que 55 piratas para 5 barcos y es la
misma razón que 121 piratas para 11 barcos. Bien,
comprobemos la respuesta y vamos al siguiente.
El siguiente problema dice: "Esta tabla muestra
razones equivalentes a 7 : 4. Completa los valores
que faltan". Este problema es muy parecido,
podemos observar que tenemos una razón de 7
: 4, y queremos buscar una razón equivalente;
entonces tenemos que multiplicar por la misma
cantidad ambas partes de la razón, es decir,
en este caso estamos multiplicando este 7 x
3 para llegar a 21, entonces si queremos una
razón equivalente tenemos que multiplicar este 4
por la misma cantidad: 4 x 3 me da 12, la razón
7 : 4 es la misma que 21 a 12. Ahora vayamos con
la siguiente fila. ¿Por qué valor multiplicamos al
4 para llegar al 16? Bueno, lo multiplicamos
por 4, por lo tanto, si queremos una razón
equivalente a 7 : 4 tendremos que multiplicar al
7 por la misma cantidad, es decir 7 x 4 me de 28,
y con esto tenemos otra fila lista. La razón 28
: 16 es la misma que 7 : 4. Ahora vayamos a la
última fila. ¿Por qué valor multiplicamos al 7
para llegar al 84? Bueno, 84 / 7 = 12, es decir,
si multiplicamos el 7 x 12 para llegar a 84,
entonces al 4 habrá que multiplicarlo por la misma
cantidad para mantener la misma razón: 4 x 2 es 48
y, por lo tanto, la razón 84 : 48 es equivalente
a la razón 7 : 4, porque estamos multiplicando
por la misma cantidad. Comprobamos la respuesta
y vamos al siguiente problema. "Las compañeras
de Diana comen brócoli y coliflor a una razón
de 12 : 7", este problema me gusta mucho. "Diana
hace una tabla para mostrar las posibilidades de
cuánto brócoli y cuánta coliflor podría comprar."
Bien, podemos darnos cuenta de que en esta tabla
no tenemos escrita la razón como tal, no tenemos
ninguna fila que nos diga 12 : 7, pero como ya
hicimos varios problemas creo que será bastante
fácil saber hacia dónde vamos. La relación es
12 : 7, así que si este 12 lo multiplico por
10 me da 120 gramos de brócoli, por lo tanto,
tenemos que multiplicar el 7 por la misma cantidad
para seguir teniendo la misma razón, así que vamos
a multiplicar 7 x 10 que nos da 70, y comerán 70
gramos de coliflor por cada 120 gramos de brócoli,
así mantenemos la misma razón de 12 : 7
en 120 : 70. Vayamos a la siguiente fila.
Tenemos 720 gramos de brócoli, ¿por qué valor
multiplicamos al 12 para llegar al 720? Bueno,
podemos traer la calculadora y dividir 720
/ 12 y obtenemos 60, por lo tanto, tenemos
que multiplicar 7 x 60 para conservar la misma
razón, vamos a multiplicar 60 x 7 y nos da 420,
así que vamos a escribirlo: 420, la razón 720
gramos de brócoli por cada 420 gramos de coliflor
es la misma que 12 gramos de brócoli por cada
7 gramos de coliflor. Por último tenemos 490,
¿por qué valor multiplicamos al 7 para llegar
al 490? Bueno, si no lo sabes al igual que yo,
podríamos sacar de nuevo la calculadora y dividir
490 / 7, esto nos da 70, 70 x 7 es lo mismo que
490, entonces si queremos mantener la misma
razón hay que multiplicar las dos cantidades
por el mismo valor: 7 x 70 es 490 y 12 x 70 es
840, vamos a escribirlo: 840 gramos de brócoli
por cada 490 de coliflor, y ya está, de nuevo
tengo la tabla completa y mantuvimos la razón de
12 : 7. Así que es hora de comprobar la respuesta
y estamos bien. Nos vemos en el siguiente video.